I can't wear fragrance because I have
sensitive skin but if I could I would
have in mind like a grilled meat
fragrance I really love it hey guys in
college I used to work at Chipotle and
today I'm bringing to pull a to BuzzFeed
that's right I'm bringing my burrito
hack straight to my co-workers to see
what they think I honestly think it is
the best combination of sweet savory
salty spicy in Chipotle all-in-one
[Music]
chipotle pepper sauce
exactly man see the cover all the time
right
[Music]
so Chipotle was probably my favorite
place in the world for a long time I
think my record was I went 26 times in a
month why that's almost every single day
my Chipotle opinion is that does Taurus
is better no offense to those Toros but
you can't replace your Pollan
[Music]
there is a lot of walking yeah I know
walk is extra never forget it so this is
a treatment they won't let you forget it
looks like something I would eat by
myself I just want to know what to do
with this lemon is it like a shot if you
take a bite and then you suck on the
lemon like tequila No
so before you take a bite you must
squeeze of lemon on to the burrito
please I'm impressed cuz a lifetime of
drinking lemon water there and I never
thought the lemon would part of the meal
squeeze in here I'm not mad at it you
know it's like yeah yeah that's really
good I'm not fun this is bangin
especially when you get like the best
from the lemon like this poppin switch
it wasn't so slimy it's just flipping
over on my hand right now like I said
something you do with your close friends
exactly no it's kind of like sweet and
spicy oh I like that yeah the sauce is
really good feeling the back on my
throat it's a little spicy but tiny bit
I'm Nigerian so no yeah it's really not
that spicy
a good mix of light so we like a tanky
zest situation happening cuz of the
lemon savory that's a spicy something
happening but it's not too much it's
like the right amount of each it's not
flavor overkill the outside of the box
tripoli they work here i think i think
you're onto something
the sweet is perfect it just needs to
like jack up on this and now i'm going
to go to Chipotle instead of dusters so
good job Jade oh yeah
in order for me to eat this I would
remove the agave that's the thing that
like really threw me off
I still love Chipotle though so I'm
never gonna give that up probably I am
now forever indebted to my awesome
co-worker Jade I just want to thank you
for introducing this to my life it's
it's definitely changed it for the
better yeah even Chipotle salads are
better than eating salad mmm that's a
quote
[Music]